so for people like gray Norton to to
know all this and to you know uh not
condemn it I I don't know how you can
sleep at night well you work with Graham
Norton on Father Ted and Father Ted I
think was his not his starting point but
certainly was a big boost in his early
career how do you feel about him saying
that cancer culture doesn't exist and
it's actually accountability culture
what am I being held accountable for
what have I done except defend women's
rights uh tried to stop people from
trolling lesbians on their own apps you
know objected to the medicalization and
the experimentation on children what
have I done why am I being held
accountable and and the reason is the
same reason as JK Rowling no reason
there's no reason I just refused to
accept a completely incoherent ideology
you know